eldon ring is the latest game from from
software and it is massive
absolutely incredibly big and as it's a
from software game it can be challenging
so i've prepared a guide for you on a
helpful beginner's route you can take
that should help you get through the
beginning of the game with that said if
an area is too difficult for you you can
always leave and come back later when
you have better weapons ashes or are a
higher level there are definitely ways
to negate challenge in this game but i
know it's easy to get lost and end up
somewhere overwhelming thanks to the
sheer scope
so without further ado let's get into it
your starting class is totally up to you
this is something you can very easily
change and customize as you progress
through the game so don't stress out
about it too much choose something that
sounds fun for more on it make sure to
check out our starting class guide by
billy givens as far as your starting
gift is concerned i'd highly recommend
choosing the golden seed golden seeds
allow you to upgrade your flasks of
tears your main healing item in the game
so you have more uses out of it before
you have to return to and rest at a site
of grace if you're new to the game first
things first make sure you don't miss
the tutorial area the cave of knowledge
as it can actually be surprisingly easy
to miss if you're an experienced player
feel free to skip it although it does
teach some of the new mechanics such as
guard countering once you've opened the
door outside of the stranded graveyard
and into limgrave the world truly is
your oyster but don't be overwhelmed
your first goal is to activate three
sites of grace as this will bring
melanoma to you who will not only give
you the ability to access torrent the
spectral steed but also the ability to
level up to easily access torrents i'd
advise signing the spectral steed
whistle to your quick item menu which
you can access in the equipment section
that way you can just hit the action key
and the corresponding directional button
to quickly call them to you this means
you won't have to spend time scrolling
through your item menu so you can
quickly escape from situations that get
a bit sticky you'll also want to find
your first map fragment so you can more
easily explore and find things in the
massive overworld your first sight of
grace is easy enough right in front of
you at the first step next you'll want
to head directly north and avoid the
tree sentinel hanging out on the path
where you'll find the church of ella
another site of grace a blacksmithing
table and kali the merchant if you need
a hand finding these three just follow
the golden path kylie the merchant sells
a number of useful items the crafting
kit will allow you to use all of the
crafting materials you've gathered
throughout the game and craft whatever
you choose i highly recommend buying a
torch here it's only 200 runes and
you'll definitely want one for the
dungeons ahead he also sells a note
about the flask of wondrous physic this
is another healing flask you can find
which can be incredibly useful
this note clues you in on the location
just northeast through the force is your
next destination this leads you to the
gatefront ruins and your first map
fragment if you need help tracking down
these map fragments open your map and
look for these icons that's where you'll
find them make sure to fully explore
these runes as there's a secret basement
that contains a whetstone which is what
allows you to equip ashes of war under
your weapons which are very useful
skills you'll find throughout the game
on top of that on the north side you'll
find a chest with the lord sworn's
greatsword while you might not have the
stats to be able to wield it yet this is
a great starting weapon for any type of
strength build and if you're new to
these games i recommend trying it out
and leveling up your strength stats to
wield it when you can the weapon's a
little slower but is powerful enough to
allow you to briefly stagger many
enemies you otherwise couldn't just by
hitting them with a two-handed attack or
even sometimes a one-handed attack not
only that but to the north west and
southeast of gate front ruins you'll
find sites of grace rest at one of these
and both torrent and the ability to
level up is yours once you've done all
of this i want you to hop on torrent and
run through the stormgate to the west of
the gatefront site of grace and follow
the path up to the stormhill shack along
the way you'll find another golden seed
which you'll definitely want as it will
allow you yet another upgrade to your
flasks of tears not only that but at the
stormhill shack you'll find an npc who
will gift you spirit jellyfish ashes in
my opinion this is an incredibly useful
spirit ash as you can use it to help
distract bosses and take their aggro
away from you however you can't use
spirit ashes yet but now that you have
torrent you can now find the spirit
calling bell which allows you to do this
first thing you need to do is rest at
your site of grace and pass time until
night as the npc who gives you this only
appears at night next warp back to the
church of ella and you'll now find the
witch rena talk to her and she'll gift
you the spirit calling bell as well as
lone wolf ashes now you have an extra
tool to aid you in combat from here
there are two dungeons i'd recommend
checking out these are stormfoot
catacombs and the grove side cave
they're low level dungeons which are
well suited for beginners and completing
these will give you a way to earn runes
and level up your character both of
these locations are along the cliffside
northwest of the church of ella
completing those your next location is
the waypoint rune cellar this is going
to be southeast of the gatefront runes
and the agile lake north side of grace
cross the bridge and find the waypoint
runes within these runes you'll find the
mad pumpkin head boss fight after
defeating him you'll find both the site
of grace and a secret location with
sorcerer's sellin selling is going to be
your way to buy new sorceries so this is
definitely a must visit location if
you're doing a sorcery style build next
we travel to the limb grave tunnels this
tunnel is north along agile lake and
north of the dragon burnt ruins you can
attempt to take on the flying dragon
aguil if you feel ready otherwise feel
free to run past him and to the bottom
of the cliffside where you'll find the
tunnel i take you here because limgrave
tunnel is filled to the brim with
smithing stones this is true the various
tunnels in every region of the game
smithing stones are your key to leveling
up your weapons so if you're doing any
kind of melee build you absolutely want
to head here early once you finish this
we're going to get that flask of
wondrous physic according to the note
from kalei it's at the third church of
america north of the mistwood so all you
need to do is go back to the waypoint
rune cellar now take the path north
don't cross the bridge but rather keep
following the path if you keep following
it to its end you'll come to the third
church america and the flask of wonders
physic there's also an artist shack
along the way with a painting you can
try to have fun and see if you can
figure out the location the painting was
painted at now we have some options
there are plenty of side dungeons to do
in the main part of limgrave and i
recommend completing these as it will
help you level up your character once
you finish this and want to explore more
rather than heading north into stormhill
in stormville castle i recommend you
head south into the weeping peninsula
this is definitely meant to be the early
game area you go to and there's plenty
to find here that will help you out
castle mourn to the south is a much
larger dungeon but much easier to
complete than stormvale and definitely
meant for lower level players not only
that but on the way to castlemourne you
can find yet another golden seed on top
of that you'll find a minor herb tree on
this peninsula which will give you more
goodies you can use for your flask of
wondrous physic and probably most
importantly there are multiple churches
on the weeping peninsula that contain
sacred tears while the golden seas
upgrade the number of uses you have out
of your flasks of tears the sacred tiers
upgrade the potency and make it so each
chug will heal you for more once again i
recommend exploring all of the weeping
peninsula for its various secrets and
dungeons which will help you level up
and strengthen your character preparing
you for stormville castle if you still
don't feel confident this might be a
good time to go explore miss wood fully
which is to the east of limgrave as well
as storm hill which is to the north side
just make sure not to venture too deeply
in the caled as that is definitely a
high level area
alright all of that done is time to
tackle stormville castle or is it if you
can might as well go ahead have fun and
see if you can conquer the challenge if
you're still struggling there's actually
a way to skip stormville castle and
travel directly into leone of the lakes
to the east side of stormville castle
just north of the stormhill shack you
can find a path that will lead you to a
broken bridge go ahead and travel to the
end of that bridge and you'll find a
crumbled path that takes you down and
through the side of the castle this will
take you right to the lake facing cliff
shrine of grace and leone of the lakes
now you can fully explore this section
and its dungeons and try to level up
even further which will help make
stormville more simple i'm not going to
go too deeply into this area but i will
say this i recommend going to carry a
manor before the academy of real lucaria
i also recommend that after you finish
reo lucaria you travel up to the atlas
plateau and lane lindell as your next
location caled is a very high level area
and while you can find it early on i
think lanedail is actually logically
supposed to come first and there you
have a beginner's guide and path to take
with eldon ring of course you're free to
alter this however you like and have fun
and explore however you want that's the
joy of this type of game but i thought
i'd give a recommended path for
beginners and something that might help
take some frustration away if you're
having trouble i also made a guide of
tips for beginning players you can also
check out right here on gamespot thanks
so much for watching and make sure to
stay tuned to gamespot for more elden
ring content
[Music]
you